[Music]
girl gets hit by car with very minor
injury oh this is funny did I send this
oh
[__] Play It Again
I love the Shania Twain playing
Smoked by the car
can we can we get this
bro bro
imagine you're filming your friend and
you're like whoa they're getting that
cart is getting you know yeah oh oh dude
she dolphined over that yeah holy [__]
dude both heels in the air
God bless her is that a PT Cruiser
what kind of car is it a Nissan driver's
probably looking at their phone but it
doesn't matter yeah yeah I say they're
both probably very in the wrong that's
probably you know it's probably better
that the driver was playing [__]
Bloons td6 it just keeps going yeah it
has no idea he had something
oh I think I ran over some [__] play the
rest she's just chilling yeah she walks
away from it she like parties well they
go to a concert yeah
it didn't look that bad it looked pretty
bad dude if you get hit by a car and you
go up on the hood I just love the timing
of that catch me like doesn't look that
bad
that car's going so slow I know what you
mean it's like coming out of a drive
parking yeah
Hospital on a neck brace yeah
dude you want to know something scary
not scary but Wild
um
sure those Phoenix uh you've seen this
[__] waymo
no don't you I could I could have you
could have you could have way more nuts
in your mouth but waymos yeah yeah
[__] cars with the the little
autonomous yeah the autonomous driving
vehicles
um so these don't have drivers no so
we're driving next to one in Phoenix and
that I've not seen one of these in
action that was the scariest [__] ever
we're just like in the car going to the
venue and we just look through the
window into one of these not a [__]
person that thing's mobbing it's doing
like [__] 50. driving completely
normally not a single person even in the
back seat so what's the point it's a
it's an app so you could just say yo I
need a ride to whatever and it'll pull
up you hop in and get in the passenger
or or it's autonomous so it just goes
for drives yeah yeah because it's like
I'm just that's kind of like what feel
the road just down the field of Road you
know I was imagining all that [__] we
were joking about like we saw go down
the street a couple times I imagine it
like just passing the street and then
just like coming back and then just
stopping at a green light and just like
turning and angling at a street corner
it's like Noel
run and it just it starts laughing at me
[Laughter]
it's like get off the sidewalk get off
the sidewalk that is [__] creepy
that's pretty unnerving yeah so but you
can order it and get in and then it'll
take you your destination to drive dude
and right now they're like free in
Arizona because they're trying to get
like tested out you know it's like we
should have done one we should have done
one we should have just mooned everyone
we should have hung out the side of the
window just
or just no hands yeah yeah
yeah that's what you should have done
gotten in the driver's seat and then
[__] yeah what can you do in there
grab the wheel or like put your dog in
the driver's seat yeah yeah yeah you
wave he's doing good right
nah man you put your head where the
pedals are and you just put your feet up
yeah exactly
we're like what the [__]
yeah
or just head on the steering wheel just
asleep
it was
driverless waymo got stuck in traffic
and then tried to run away from its
support crew dude I'm telling you man
JJ Ricks buckle up this one is wild JJ
Rick's here in the waymo running away
I would love to take one of these
just watching it accelerate to the back
of a semi
you're like this sucks
waymo you want to chill out
and then post in the YouTube video about
it
so yeah as you can see here this is when
my waymo accelerated directly into the
semi
um my head hurts but I'm fine
I will be taking more waymos in the
future yep
oh that's scary as [__] you're a nervous
how nervous you just laughed oh
well that was a close one
oh
dude press play
true
true he just shoot himself a little bit
[Laughter]
fixed itself what do you know car runs
away
waymo gets road rage and Chase's guy
Chase's guy to Costco and tries to kill
him
oh there's like a waymo support guy yeah
yeah yeah yes uh well a little bit and
then it's
this is
um now it's I will be [__] my pants
do they
find car finally stopped for good
oh my God imagine that doors are locking
and then it just drives straight towards
a cliff Cody we're going for a wild ride
yeah
waymo you don't need to do this no
damn I I I would kind of want to take
one of those I see them all the time
here are they here too yeah they're like
yeah getting a survey of the roads and
stuff so that they can they're just
mapping right now I think so you can't
actually order one here
see a waymo in La will be way more
cooler
oh yeah dude well it would actually work
because there's no [__] there's
nowhere to go yeah like the traffic is
so brutal it's like you can't really
Drive unsafe yeah I saw this Tick Tock
the other day of a police trying to pull
over awaymo I just sent it to you Luke
uh
and he's like in the passenger's like I
don't what the [__] do you want me to do
like I'm like is this is this a Google
company or is it like Tesla or something
I cannot no we're sorry
we're sorry this car won't let us move
sorry not that we can do he's like pull
over to the side
there's no one in the drive dog that's
so funny
the waymo's like a cab and then just
just
bro it's too bright he doesn't know
there's no driver
Metro Phoenix
they were like every single Street yeah
man really yeah like we like no joke
we're like well I think it's falling
like whatever but it was like every
single place so many why Phoenix because
it's that [__] place is Blade Runner
2049 man
it's destitute it's scary out there man
I said this [__] at the show yesterday
I'm like after like having traveled a
ton
like it's crazy to see someone like
hopped up on some [__] in like 110
degrees just dancing on the street yeah
like in front of like an abandoned
business it's and then away mode just
like
that [__] is dystopian man really yeah
yeah Phoenix God bless them out there
and they're like No One's Gonna Give a
[__] a couple cards crash yeah just
because there's no [__] business
that's open to you know like if it
crashed into old like used car lot like
no one owns it to care
waymos rule that place damn that's the
waymo Kingdom so are they cheaper they
must be cheaper yeah how much is waymo
cheaper than what Ubers
oh I think I mean in certain parts of
Arizona they're free they're free oh my
God if you're willing risk your life
yeah for a free ride yeah a free ride in
it the rides are free the company does
not have yet does not yet have approval
to charge fees fares
but I mean assuming once they do charge
it'll be like you don't have to pay
anyone
he got a bit of company you just have to
pay well the company just has a charge
for the use of the car which but they'd
probably be able literally like 10 cents
for that job so they're gonna do why
would they do that they're gonna do what
talal would do to your pickleball League
yeah they're gonna come under do the
Walmart make it cheaper but they
actually can because the cars are
probably cheap as [__] yeah but then
they'll murder Uber and then they'll be
like guess what
hundred dollars a mile
yeah
but yes to start they're Jaguars they
are jaguars
that's pretty sick
that's how you know that
good torque for when they punch it right
towards the yeah dude yeah
that's one of Jaguar is safest is when
no one is driving it
'd be so funny to like call one of those
outside of a bar or something yeah and
it picks you up I'm like sick thanks
what stops
just grab someone out the line waiting
to go into a club
[Music]
it's locked I can't get out bye you're
going to San Diego
we're in Portland I know
have fun bye
the doors are locked it won't let me out
I was thinking about how funny it would
be if you got in the car and you're like
all right guys yeah see you later my
waymo is here you got in and then it
just like drove into the side of the
boat
[Music]
oh get out damn it [__] dude yeah these
waymos are not this is not it
I'm gonna take a bird